imagine that when you walked in here
this evening you discovered that
everybody in the room looked almost
exactly the same
ageless raceless generically
good-looking that person sitting right
next to you might have the most
idiosyncratic inner life but you don't
have a clue because we're all wearing
the same blank expression all the time
that is the kind of creepy
transformation that is taking over
cities only it applies to buildings not
people cities are full of roughness and
shadow texture and color you can still
find architectural surfaces of great
individuality and character in apartment
buildings in Riga and Yemen social
housing in Vienna Hopi villages in
Arizona round stones in New York wooden
houses in San Francisco
these aren't palaces or cathedrals these
are just ordinary residences expressing
the ordinary splendor of cities and the
reason they're like that is that the
need for shelter is so bound up with the
human desire for beauty their rough
surfaces give us a touchable city great
streets that you can read by running
your fingers over brick and stone but
that's getting harder to do because
cities are becoming smooth new
downtown's sprout towers that are almost
always made of concrete and steel and
covered in glass you can look at
skylines all over the world
Houston Guangzhou Frankfurt and you see
the same army of high gloss robots
marching over the horizon now just think
of everything we lose when architects
stop using the full range of available
materials when we reject great
anat limestone and sandstone and wood
and copper and terracotta and brick and
wattle and plaster we simplify
architecture and we impoverish cities
it's as if you reduced all of the
world's cuisines down to airline food
chicken or pasta but we're still
Assemblies of glass towers like this one
in Moscow suggest a disdain for the
Civic and communal aspects of urban
living right buildings like these are
intended to enrich their owners and
tenants but not necessarily the lives of
the rest of us those of us who navigate
the spaces between the buildings and we
expect to do so for free shinee towers
are an invasive species and they are
choking our cities and killing off
public space we tend to think of a
facade as being like make up a
decorative layer applied at the end to a
building that's effectively complete but
just because a facade is superficial
doesn't mean it's not also deep let me
give you an example of how a city
surfaces affect the way we live in it
when I visited Salamanca in Spain I
gravitated to the plaza my yard at all
hours of the day
Riley in the morning sunlight rakes the
facades sharpening shadows and at night
lamplight segments the buildings into
hundreds of distinct areas balconies and
windows and arcades each one a separate
pocket of visual activity that detail
and depth that glamour gives the plaza a
theatrical quality it becomes a stage
where the generations can meet you have
teenagers sprawling on the pavers
seniors monopolizing the benches and
real life starts to look like an opera
set the curtain goes up on Salamanca so
just because I'm talking about the
exteriors of buildings not form not
function not structure
even so those surfaces give texture to
our lives because buildings create the
spaces around them and those spaces can
draw people in or push them away and the
difference often has to do with the
quality of those exteriors so one
contemporary equivalent of the plaza
mayor in salamanca is the plaster lady
falls in Paris a windswept glass walled
open space that office workers hurried
through on their way from the metro to
their cubicles but otherwise spend as
little time and as possible in the early
1980s the architect Philip Johnson tried
to recreate a gracious European Plaza in
Pittsburgh this is PPG place a half acre
of open space encircled by commercial
buildings made of mirrored glass any
ornamented those buildings with metal
trim and bays and gothic turrets which
really pop on the skyline but at ground
level the plaza feels like a black glass
cage I mean sure in summertime kids are
running back and forth through the
fountain and there's ice skating in the
winter but it lacks the informality of a
leisurely hangout it's just not the sort
of place you really want to just hang
out and chat public spaces thrive or
fail for many different reasons
architecture is only one but it's an
important one
some recent plazas like Federation
Square in Melbourne or super Keelan in
Copenhagen succeed because they combine
old and new rusts and smooth neutral and
bright colors
and because they don't rely excessively
on glass now I'm not against glass it's
an ancient and versatile material it's
easy to manufacture and transport and
install and replace and clean it comes
in everything from enormous ultra clear
sheets to translucent bricks new
coatings make
change mood in the shifting light in
expensive cities like New York it has
the magical power of being able to
multiply real-estate values by allowing
views which is really the only commodity
that developers have to offer to justify
those surreal prices in the middle of
the 19th century with the construction
of the Crystal Palace in London glass
left to the top of the list of
quintessentially modern substances by
the mid 20th century it had come to
dominate the downtown's of some American
cities largely through some really
spectacular office buildings like lever
house in midtown Manhattan designed by
Skidmore Owings and Merrill eventually
the technology advanced to the point
where architects could design structures
so transparent they practically
disappeared and along the way glass
became the default material of the
high-rise city and there's a very
powerful reason for that because as the
world's populations converge on cities
the least fortunate [ __ ] into
jerry-built shanty towns but hundreds of
millions of people need apartments and
places to work in ever larger buildings
so it makes economic sense to put up
towers and wrap them in cheap and
practical curtain walls but glass has a
limited ability to be expressive this is
a section of wall framing a plaza and
the pre-hispanic city of mitla in
southern Mexico those two
thousand-year-old carvings make it clear
that this was a place of high ritual
significance today we look at those and
we can see a historical and textural
continuity between those carvings the
mountains all around and that church
which is built on top of the ruins using
stone plundered from the site in nearby
Oaxaca even ordinary plaster buildings
become canvases for bright colors
political murals and sophisticated
graphic arts it's an intricate
communicative language that an epidemic
of glass would simply wipe out the good
news is that architects and
peppers have begun to rediscover the
joys of texture without backing away
from modernity some find innovative uses
for old materials like bricks and
terracotta others invent new products
like the molded panels that Snohetta
used to give their San Francisco Museum
of Modern Art that crinkly sculptural
quality the architect Stefano Pilati
even created living facades
this is his vertical forest a pair of
apartment towers in Milan whose most
visible feature is greenery and Belletti
is designing a version of this for
Nanjing in China and imagine if green
facades were as ubiquitous as glass ones
how much cleaner the air in Chinese
cities would become but the truth is
that these are mostly one offs boutique
projects not easily reproduced at a
global scale and that is the point when
you use materials that have a local
significance you prevent cities from all
looking the same copper has a long
history in New York the Statue of
Liberty the crown of the Woolworth
Building but it fell out of fashion for
a long time until shop architects used
it to cover the American copper building
a pair of twisting towers on the East
River it's not even finished and you can
see the way sunset lights up that
metallic facade which will weather to
green as it ages buildings can be like
people their faces broadcast their
experience and that's an important point
because when glass ages you just replace
it and the building looks pretty much
the same way it did before until
eventually it's demolished almost all
other materials have the ability to
absorb infusions of history and memory
and project it into the present the firm
Aeneid clad the Utah Natural History
Museum in Salt Lake City in copper and
zinc ores that have been mined in the
area for 150 years
and that also camouflaged the building
against the ochre hills so that you have
a Natural History Museum that reflects
the region's Natural History and when
the Chinese Pritzker Prize winner Wang
Shu was building a History Museum in
Ningbo he didn't just create a wrapper
for the past he built memory right into
the walls by using brick and stones and
shingles salvaged from villages that had
been demolished
now architects can use glass in equally
lyrical and inventive ways here in New
York two buildings one by Jean Nouvel
and this one by Frank Gehry face off
across West 19th Street and the play of
reflections that they tossed back and
forth is like a symphony in light but
when a city defaults to glass as it
grows it becomes a Hall of Mirrors
disquieting and cold after all cities
are places of concentrated variety where
the world cultures and languages and
lifestyles come together and mingle so
rather than in case all that variety and
diversity in buildings of crushing
sameness we should have an architecture
that honors the full range of the urban
experience thank
[Applause]